here's something cool I got some facts
on the great grad school okay what's
this about you peed in your pants during
the 1987 Canada Cup game he peed his
pants yeah why'd you pee in your pants
in 87 we played in what was called the
World Cup yeah and we went into double
overtime it was I guess the way to
compare is like a triathlon when you've
just your body breaks down and you lose
control because you're eating and
working so much yeah no just I just was
so drained and tired Wow
just sitting on the bench and all of a
sudden in the middle of a game and you
were like really burned out I mean you
retired you would put all your energy
because you're the great Gretzky and you
put everything into a game you know you
always want to win and everything you're
great competitor and like out of all
this fatigue suddenly you lost control
of your bladder which is the only time
it happened by the way right it sound
like you're incontinent and you were
fully suited up right and to get suited
up takes quite a bit of a work so you're
sitting there and all of a sudden you
realize you have no control of your
bladder and you really pee in your pants
right and like while you were peeing all
this feels good but I'm very embarrassed
[Applause]
I'm like when this happened you get
embarrassed you turn to your teammates
and say listen I just peed in my pants
you did hey what are you baby
did you play the rest of the game with
wet pants Yeah right did you smell yeah
hey what's with your superstitions or
something you talk to your jersey in on
your left side what is that all about
and you even had it sewn into your pants
so it can't come as dishes when I start
playing I was six and at the time I
could only play with 11 year old kids
because there's no other kids at six
years old right so everyone got a
sweater in those days your sweater was
made for 11 year old so my sweater went
down to my ankles right so my dad said
you look too small so to make me look a
little bigger he took my sweater and
he'd tuck it in ever since then it kind
of it's been lucky did you ever play
without your sweater tucked in you know
really and what happened you have a bad
game bad years really really and now
that you would the Rangers are you happy
because you're back with Messier I love
it here and you took a pay cut to come
here right yeah the best thing about New
York is people says you know people are
crazy they're so rude through this
they're pretty aggressive they're nice
people are very nice well I have enjoyed
my time right I mean you also meet nice
people go to hockey games that's not
really this street and you met nice
people oh yeah and I watched it on TV
sometimes it's fun yeah you know what
the thing about hockey is compared to
any other sport you can watch sports on
TV and go to it and there's not that big
of a difference if you watch hockey on
TV and then go to the game it's a
different experience this year they in
their sports some thing they've actually
run a promotion they're going to feature
the fights yeah you know they're gonna
pull one out of these wheels will be the
best part week will be honored
you get into fights no how come no one
fights with you because you're the great
Gretzky I told the guys once in the nose
I'd noise start crying I mean I did
Janet isn't gonna for a guy who can't
fight a great one why are you visiting
today you promoting anything you just
come by to say hi Gary asked me to the
shore wow that's deep yeah we love the
great one